[Musik]
bild breaking news
an guten morgen und wir beginnen gleich
mit breaking news ja wirklich
dramatische szenen die sich am abend in
solingen abgespielt haben bei einer
tödlichen messerstecherei der stirbt ein
31 jähriger und ein weiterer mann
offenbar der vater des opfers der wird
schwer verletzt unsere reporter haben
exklusive augenzeugen videos
schreie in der dunkelheit stimmengewirr
die hassel straße in solingen am abend
tatort einer tödlichen messerstecherei
am späten abend die vier in solingen
eine größere personengruppe in streit
geraten ein mann soll dann ein messer
gezogen haben und hat dem späteren opfer
die klingel mehrfach in den körper
gerammt die stiche trafen den mann in
herz und den hals er biete noch einige
momente stehen und sagte dann
blutüberströmt zusammen
zeugen und der herbeigerufene notarzt
versuchen noch die person zu reanimieren
doch jede hilfe kommt zu spät das opfer
stirbt noch am tatort mindestens eine
weitere person wird durch stiche
verletzt offenbar der vater des
getöteten wenig später wird der
mutmaßliche täter von der polizei
festgenommen wir haben dann umfangreiche
fahndungsmaßnahmen
eingeleitet im rahmen dieser
fahndungsmaßnahmen konnten die beamten
auch eine männliche tatverdächtige
person vorläufig festnehmen die art und
weise der beteiligung an dieser
auseinandersetzung ist derzeit noch
gegenstand der ermittlungen ebenso die
hintergründe und zu dem sachverhalt was
ist hier eigentlich passiert ist derzeit
noch sehr unklar die kriminalpolizei
sperrt den tatort weiträumig ab zur
spurensicherung und auch weil immer mehr
familienangehörige am ort des schreckens
eintreffen eine mordkommission hat die
ermittlungen aufgenommen
[Musik]